it's now time to turn to my right
welcome in my next two guests here from
the film Top Gun maverick which is in
theaters near you coming up in June but
it's never too early to front-load you
to know that the latest iteration of Top
Gun is coming again to a theater near
you enjoyed this man's work in whiplash
and this man's work also in hidden
figures respectively miles teller and
Glen Powell good to see you guys here on
the rich Johnson you got a nice setup
thank you appreciate that a bright we're
gonna make a run before to go sunglasses
and when we heard them going for I mean
- I mean you don't have a VA ders ready
to help promote you know we'll what's up
with that I know I assumed we were gonna
have some sort of Raymond sponsorship
after this thing they have to buy them
just like everyone I mean yeah spent
every dime I had on this movie buying
Ray Bans that I lose we got to get on
paramount right I mean or is it or or
hold on a second you just tell me is Tom
Cruise the only one who's allowed to
wear those in promotion of the film I
mean oh I don't know she was right here
did we I don't know there's so much
stuff we can't talk about so I'm just
gonna skip onto the next one
yeah cuz there cuz you can't you can't
miles you can't right reveal too much of
what's going I know it's just tricky cuz
they want it you know it's like hey go
down and you know talk about Top Gun but
don't talk about don't talk about it too
much you know don't talk about the movie
you don't know what we're gonna talk
about here first rule of Fight Club also
first rule of Top Chef
yeah it's the same thing yeah it's the
same exact thing what we can say though
is miles your character is the son of
the dearly departed goose yes
spoiler alert spoiler alert yeah I look
up in the sky and point up let me Dad
and you your character Glenn is hangman
correct yes and that and who is who is
hangman can we say that he's the UH is
the greatest weapon the US Navy's ever
produced okay okay
that's I think once people see the film
very much debatable and I don't want it
I don't want to again have any spoilers
is there a danger zone in this film is
it is it physical dangers of the romani
Loggins is is please tell me Loggins is
doing Loggins was on set
every day singing us into huge scene
that's got you into debt gotcha it's in
Massena did the whole soundtrack don't
you think yeah no I would love that
so I I can't imagine just like everybody
else you know you grew up seeing Top Gun
and it meant a lot what in the hell was
it like being on the set of Top Gun Tom
Cruise there you're going to do it all
again I remember the first we're all
down in Fallon Nevada where Top Gun is
and you know I think we're getting like
fitted or Thomas about to go up for a
flight and he put the maverick helmet on
for the first time and I just I started
a maverick chant and that was yeah that
was a pretty surreal moment yeah it's
such a legendary character like you said
for so many different generations this
movie came out before I was born and for
a lot of my friends it is their favorite
movie and they are pissed off that I'm
in it what are they they're pissed off
my first friends they just are always
like man I would love that movie if you
weren't in it just cuz they have a hard
time right you know seeing seeing the
character whatever it is I have great
friends you need to upgrade your friends
that you don't friends or do you need no
this whole press tour is miles trying to
find friends just here oh I'm more than
happy to do that
okay then be happy for him to be in this
movie I don't understand what was it
like when you were in an oscar-nominated
film Myles what was it like were they
like did they do good day just like his
mom Sean how dare you did they shun you
when you were in whiplash I mean what's
that oh you know I don't know it's it's
good man they're just like my buddies
I've had my you know my whole life so
that's good they keep me in check okay
and what was it like for you point on
that set
I mean Top Gun is one of the reasons I
became an actor you know Tom Cruise is
my favorite actor are you serious yeah
absolutely
absolutely it's like when I was a kid I
was I was 10 years old my dad showed me
Top Gun it was like a big moment it was
you know one of his favorite movies and
it was like teaching you how to throw a
baseball for the first time there's
something he was so excited to show me
because it was something that I feel
like it was it's like a moment for a dad
to a son and so to be on set my dad got
to be in the movie
you know when nobody's family finds the
lens more than the palace
it was it was incredible I'm gonna see
with you how they could just find the
Lance you told me though you you wanted
to become an actor because you realize
that in early age that you were just
incredibly good-looking that was always
what you told me yeah I found my face in
a spoon and I never looked back you know
what there's two things that if you're
incredibly good-looking ruggedly and
we're speaking from experience well yeah
obviously is that there's well then I
guess there's three things one you can
become an actor too you could become a
talk show host or three or three become
the quarterback of the New England
Patriots lead some way shape or form and
Jimmy if he is now Jimmy GQ yeah it's
out here right yeah and Carson Wentz you
know I would die on and that I'll go
I'll go with that one it's got an
audience Carson Wentz like considered
like pretty attractive it's really funny
because and this is no offense to
anybody in our studio audience I know
that your people know by the way that we
have come up on this show that if you
say the words with all due respect to
start a sentence now you are free to be
disrespectful after that you inoculate
yourself with the words and with all due
respect life I'm ready so with all due
respect to you know our studio audience
this entire week you could make them
clap over anything like literally say
the word cereal people will clap you
know who loves Syria over here who loves
Top Gun who loves talking
who thinks Carson Wentz's as handsome as
Jimmy J oh that's one is one lady my man
my man in the bird shirt they are drunk
they're drunk morning day drinking all
morning you're the Rich Eisen show so it
means you're an Eagles fan yeah okay all
Philly except for except for baskets my
dad was a big Jerry West fan so I
inherited Lakers and Notre Dame from him
Notre Dame yeah you know I'm a Michigan
guy so I watch Rudy hoping he pops his
quad at the end of the film Rudy was
offsides Rudy was ice man don't you
think but you gotta love the spirit
trying to you know jump in the snap
count he was in the neutral zone he
might have even lined up in the neutral
zone funny that we're descending to that
movie would just be a flag on the play
it's Rudy getting tossed him self
outside the stadium for nothing Lee goes
back for nothing unless yeah Charles
duck just loved neutral zone infraction
they're just clapping slowly for no
reason other than all that Glenn what's
your team you know what's funny is
actually regarding Michigan my dad went
to Ohio State the only time I've ever
seen my dad is the most Zen cool guy
ever yes
the only time I've ever seen him lose it
was when Charles Woodson ruined remember
that and the Rose Bowl like oh my gosh
yeah well no he threw a bowl of
pistachios through the TV through the
television that is such a dad by the way
you said the nobody finds the lens quite
like the Powell family so when Charles
Woodson went the distance from my alma
mater against the Ohio State yes as you
know you've got to say it's the Ohio
State University when is a trademark
thee you can absolutely confuse it from
an Ohio State University no idea which
Ohio State University has to be viable
and so when he spoiled it for that year
which by the way might be the last time
that my alma mater had a moment like
that against this this you guys have had
a
we're drunk I know I have to learn it I
have to own it I love that rivalry so I
like Michigan being great I love when
those two in the most epic way okay I
went to University of Texas so I'm he's
a long one okay there you go
I'm I'm feeling good about the future
but you know obviously we got a lot to
prove so so miles you play fantasy
football I do yeah I've heard that yeah
who do you what league are you in I'm in
one of Barry's 3000 leagues Matthew
berry another one I was in the AG Bo one
where they donated the the winnings for
charity of your choice at Hemsworth won
but okay yeah so I got like 20,000
donated to Nami health okay and then
yeah I'm in one with my buddies from
high school and then I'm in another kind
of student I believe how many is to pick
them and I also you know just like she's
so fluctuating I really just want to get
back to the purity of it where I'm like
Eagles win I'm happy sure if they lose
I'm upset oh that's too much cuz if I
lose money and the you know right so
long you bet you bet while we were
shooting the movie that was it always
determined your mood for the day I
always nearly you know and because you
don't just bet on the Eagles you bet on
a lot of it I'm emotional very emotional
yeah okay miles teller and Glen Powell
from Top Gun maverick in theaters near
you on the 26th of June we're going to
see a clip of that in a second game
prediction time presented by DIRECTV 4k
quick reminder that the big game on
Sunday is brought to you by 4k HDR and
DirecTV okay guys who do you have Kansas
City or San Francisco in this one what
do you got miles you forgot San
Francisco yeah
3834 now you can see that there is a
somebody who wagers quite a bit giving a
score I'm gonna punish it for the nine
years you're gonna tease it for the
nineties it for the Niners to see how an
NFL employee not allowed to gamble so
when you use words like that I have no
earthly idea what you're talking about
teasing it I have no clue that kind of
takes all the fun of about being an NFL
employee when you can you know what it's
still fun regardless I still have some
fun doing it what about you Glenn I'm
taking the cheese touchdown okay they're
wearing can see t-shirt I just said you
like a hot attract right oh yeah okay if
you just stop talking about the
attractiveness of quarterbacks and
actually talk about football it's all
the same to me
yeah yeah so which one of you guys
handle being a cockpit better anybody
pass out what'd he say did anybody pass
out on shooting this nobody passed out
no it was about so there's a group we
got six of us and a 50%
we're puking honestly up even until the
last day one time I had to get in the
cockpit after Glenn had just come back
from the flight and it's intense I'm not
trying to downplay that I see Glenn I'm
like hey man how'd it go he's like oh
man went gray like got all the shots
everything he's like crushed it man
anyway I'll see ya I go I'm walking up
to the jet and they're just like in the
jet I always put it inside when you puke
whether it's stayed in your mouth I
never donated he's probably a Cowboys
fan you know stuff like that
is he human lining you close is he is he
unfairly maligning you right now I
started off really really strong Chuck
in the jet and then checked - I started
off strong in the jet and then over the
course of it once you start pulling
these G's yeah where the blood is
draining from your head and once I had
this like Pavlovian response where like
I was like I got in the jet I was like
you know what I should give in I know
it's gonna happen it's very intense up
there at us I mean look the fact that
you know yeah you have a bag down here
you know Glenn or whoever you you you
feel sick
pick bag help Jude locked away and and
then you still like flying around for
another hour
well I didn't even love you clearly
didn't lock it away you have your hand
on the stick with it but then I had to
have the bag of puke here because you
can't put it back in maybe that should
be your fantasy team name next year's
bag of puke what do you think you got an
avatar miles I don't know I'm just
throwing that out there
bag of puke it's funny we had Rob Lowe
on the show and he was telling stories
about basically did he rollin up she'll
even wear the show that no he did not
he he was on the show basically telling
stories about growing out with Tom
Cruise and saying that crew Tom Cruise
refers to his movies that he's done with
just one word like you know he would
talk about gun or mission does he do
that did you witness now it goes in this
business to know what it is but somebody
like oh yeah I was on pirates or oh yeah
I was on you know yeah they just they
chunk a debt well what would it be
before it would whip or what buddy Blash
were you an lash or you wanna whip yeah
you did figures you know and people know
what you talk yeah absolutely it sounds
cool right
not it's the coolest thing ever it's
really cool pirates is cooler than lash
say that gun mission yeah there's
another I don't think guns gonna stick
now of July this it's born it's got to
be born it's born
yeah no you already got well this one's
Top Gun maverick and again it's in
theaters on June 26th where you're gonna
see a clip of it miles teller and Glen
Powell right here on the Rich Eisen show
everybody that's an applause line right
now there you go
[Applause]
the windchill is our personal a set
dancing son-of-a-gun
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app